We have just an awful lot of corn starch,
some containers to mix stuff up
and a bunch of orange glow sticks.
We're going to find out if we can make
oobleck that glows like lava.
[Captions by Mikee M at Y Translator]
[theme music]
TKOR THE KING OF RANDOM
Hey guys, not too long ago,
we had a video showing you
how to make glowing ooze
using borax, glue and some glow sticks.
On that video, user Copper Corsair
commented asking if we could mix
the glow fluid with
corn flour and make Oobleck.
Assuming he meant cornstarch,
we're going to try that out.
As a first experiment,
let's see what happens if we
just drain all the fluid
out of a glow stick,
mix in some cornstarch
and see if that turns into the non-Newtonian
fluid we're used to playing with.
[music]
We are going to mix
both of these fluids together
before adding the corn starch.
So let's turn down the lights
so we can see the glow effect.
I'll crack the glass tubes,
pour them off into this cup,
and then pour them from the cup
into the other container.
[music]
That is beautiful.
Liquid fire in a container.
Let's start adding cornstarch
into this mixture and see
if we can get that really
weird texture we're looking for.
[music]
All right.
Now we've got it to a point
where it's turning into
sort of a goopy mess.
But, normally when you have Oobleck,
it's actually very hard to stir
because trying to push it with
the spoon just makes it get firm.
And then when you let it sit,
it settles down into more of a liquid.
This stuff, however, is just...
sort of...
goopy.
It's just kind of like a pudding.
Squishing it doesn't make it firm up.
It just stays semi-liquid.
So while it is glowing,
I wouldn't call it Oobleck at this point.
Let's mix up a batch with normal
water and cornstarch to see a comparison.
[music]
Oh I'm starting to run into
the problem I was talking about.
I'm having a hard time stirring it,
Because as I put pressure
on it to stir,
It all firms up.
You just have to stir very
slowly and calmly.
Go quick,
it can even peel it
off of the bottom.
This stuff is so weird.
All right.
At this point, I think we
have successfully created Oobleck.
In that it's a liquid while it's in the container.
We can sort of scoop it up and it can
even crumble if we're quick enough.
There we go, I've got a ball of it
that I'm able to just
hold and pass between my hands,
as long as I keep it rolling.
Once I stop,
it just puddles everywhere.
Let's see what happens
if we mix one into the other.
[music]
The oil-like substance
that's in the glowsticks,
does not do a good job of mixing with water,
when there's no cornstarch involved.
At this point, we're getting
sort of a crumbly mess.
I think we may need more
water to combine with the cornstarch
that was mixed with the glowstick fluid.
That looks like radioactive
cottage cheese or something.
[music]
I'm kinda liking how
this is looking now.
I'm now able to handle this
Oobleck and if I stop...
it puddles off just like normal Oobleck.
So we're pretty much
where we want to be on consistency.
But, it doesn't have as much
glow as I would like.
So I'm going to try cracking open a
couple more glow sticks,
and adding those in as well.
Some activator fluid and it's
already reacting
with what was already in the Oobleck.
[music]
Well, our glowing Oobleck
wasn't really glowing too much.
Then, I remembered, we've used soap
to bring out the glow...
extra bright in the past.
And soap might be able  to make
the two liquids, water and the glow fluid,
bond together a little bit and holy cow!
That seems to be the key.
We now have an Oobleck substance
that is glowing very brightly.
[music]
I should point out that this is
not the exact same texture
as normal Oobleck.
It has a little bit of just a putty texture
even when you let it sit.
It does stay firm if you handle it,
and it does start
to liquefy if you let it sit.
But, it doesn't get as liquid or as firm,
as Oobleck without glow fluid in it.
Well, you know what,
this worked pretty well.
And I just got to keep going.
I want to try this with another color.
Let's see if we can make blue.
[music]
There's a little bit of contamination
because I'm using the same cup,
to hold the dye that was
for the other experiments.
But...
That is such a cool color.
I actually like that contamination,
It gave a little
tiny tint of greenish white.
We've got sort of an aqua glow going on.
Start by adding some of our corn starch.
See if we can mix up that gooey substance.
That isn't Oobleck.
It's just sort of...
glowing pudding.
It's slimy and it's gooey
and it's glowing,
but it's definitely not Oobleck.
Same as before, let's mix up a
batch of Oobleck that doesn't glow.
and then mix the two together
[music]
Add in a little bit of water
and try and smooth it out.
[music]
Immediately starts reacting.
As we mix,
it starts reacting even more.
[music]
I've got a new batch of
green glowing Oobleck or,
think I'll call it Goobleck.
Glowing Oobleck.
I have a new batch of green
Goobleck mixed up.
And I want to try something
that I've seen some other people do.
This is a subwoofer speaker,
that's attached to an
amplifier going into my phone...
which is playing a tone generator.
Meaning if I press play on my phone,
this will start playing one precise frequency.
It can even go louder than that,
but that's not necessary yet.
What we want to try is putting our
non-Newtonian fluid in the speaker.
When a speaker is turned on,
it's actually moving back and forth
at a very precise frequency.
The frequency is determined by
the tone that I choose
to play out of the tone generator.
A higher pitched noise
means a higher frequency.
A lower pitched
noise is a lower frequency.
I really want to see how this looks
with our non-Newtonian fluid
sitting right on top of the cone
where the sound comes from.
[music]
Little growths.
On screen, this actually kind of
looks out of focus,
but it's because it's vibrating
at a frequency
that looks blurry on camera.
It actually looks
a little blurry in person even.
It's kind of funny when I poke it.
It feels rigid not like a liquid.
I want to see what happens
if I shine a black light on this.
[music]
Mmm... it looks alive.
Guys, if you think Oobleck
is fun to play with,
you really should try Goobleck.
The Glowing Oobleck.
It's slimy, it's soft,
and it's durable.
Not very good at
writing commercial slogans.
Copper Corsair, thank you for your
suggestion to try making glowing Oobleck.
Check your YouTube inbox
and we're sending you 25 bucks.
Guys, there's still more for you see.
That little box up at the top
will transport you
directly to our last video.
You should go check it out.
The box at the bottom will show you
what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and this bomb right here will subscribe you
to our channel so you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.